hello everyone I hope you're all doing
great and before I show you the game I
would just like to say one thing the
person in the thumbnail isn't really a
Martin J Gordon as I couldn't really
find a single photo of this person so
this is just a random person from the
internet and that's why instead of the
quote above the board there is a pleat
for me if any of you are able to find at
least one photo of Martin J Gordon
please send it to me so I can update the
thumbnail okay
that being said Martin J Gordon was from
England and he was the under-16 champion
of England in 1967 and in 1968 he was
the under-18 champion of England and
this game was played in 1970 he's
playing against an unknown player but
just to show you that he was an
incredibly strong chess player also in
1970 in the great tournament in Hastings
he defeated the former world champion
vasily smyslov so definitely a strong
player I don't think he ever achieved
the title of Grandmaster I think he got
to the International Master as his peak
rating was around 20 450 and I've seen a
lot of games in this variation I will
show you and a lot of a lot of them were
pretty quick kills and there were pretty
fancy combinations but this one is is
definitely an amazing one and I hope it
I hope the title fits as I nee I will
name this video Britain's Got Talent
so let's see the game Martin J Gordon is
white and his opponent is black we have
E 4 E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
to c4 so detail in game Knight to f6 we
have the two Knights defense b4 we have
you capture Sun d4 and now white castles
and well this is a pretty old line as
you'll see black plays Knight captures
on e4 and this by no means is good for
white or good for black this is
considered to be an equal position but
you know in practice well it's never the
case always one player prevails white
plays rook to e1 he now pins this night
as
well there is a king gone yet after all
and black defends this with d5 now
protecting the night and also attacking
this bishop on c4 and well here's the
idea of this opening white plays Bishop
captures on d5 so it's seems like a
piece a curved ice but it's really not
we have 20 capture Sun d5 and now Knight
to c3 and now you see that this Knight
cannot be captured either with this
depot nor would the night since the
knight is pinned from the rook and if if
pawn captures then Queen captures Queen
and d5 so we have a Queen to a5 and now
Knight captures on e4 so white wins back
the piece and black plays Bishop to e6
and this is all very good for black as
you can see both black and white are
pretty known to this the theory of this
opening Martin plays Bishop to d2 now
attacking the Queen and we have a queen
to f5 and now Bishop to g5 as what this
is a pretty good move it stops black
from castling queenside and well this is
the critical position in the game as in
this position black shouldn't really
allow this Bishop to stay on g5 he
should have played something like h6 and
well force White's to decide what to do
with the bishop but black thought why
waste time with with h6 I better develop
my piece with a temple like Bishop to b4
now I'm attacking this rook anyone and
after white it deals with this all
simply Castle kingside and always well
but this was actually a pretty bad move
as Martin will show Martin plays Knight
captures on d4 and this is now with the
tempo on the Queen so we have a nice
capture Sun d4 and now Martin plays
Queen captures on d4 so he wants to
sacrifice the exchange here with Bishop
captures and e1 and let's see what would
happen if black played is if Bishop
captures anyone would have Queen
captures on g7 now threatening if the
captured orokin a trade and notice that
the black still can't Castle queenside
since the bishop is still on the g5 and
well you probably you don't want to lose
this piece here so it probably wanna at
least capture on F to for example Bishop
captures I have to with check and after
Knight characters at least grabbing a
point
you have to protect the rooks or
something like rook to f8 and after rook
to e1 black would have a terrible time
playing this position as this Bishop is
pinned the Queen can't really go
anywhere because rook captures an e6 is
threatening with Queen to e7 checkmate
so this would be this wouldn't be
enjoyable for black at all so after this
going to d4 move black decided not to go
for this and he played Bishop to f8 but
this is actually this is actually a
catastrophic move as white will show
white plays rook a to d1 and this is
this comes with a terrible threat of
Queen to d8 check and then after the
Queen is captured recapture 78 with
checkmate so Blanc decided to stop this
and he decided to stop this well there
really isn't a way to stop this but
probably the best move would be Bishop
to d6 but he he tried f6 now stopping
the threat of Bishop recovering this is
da it's worse so Queen to d8 is no
longer possible but here he allows white
a spectacular matin 5 and I will I will
let you find find the idea for ourselves
as it's it's probably the best amazing
sequence I've seen in this variation so
yeah I will give it a couple of seconds
if you want to check it out for
ourselves okay and if not well the move
is a brilliant one it's Queen to d7
check and there is no move for black the
black King can go anywhere do only the
only playable move is Bishop captures
Queen so we have Bishop captures Queen
and now Martin plays Knight to d6 would
check from the knight and also this
cover check from the rope anyone and
this is for King the king and the Queen
on f5 so only move and yeah most
important is covering the f7 squares so
only move for the black king is king to
d8
and now of course not capturing the
Queen but nice to f7 check and again
there is only one move for the black
King he plays King to c8 and the well if
you didn't find the idea then maybe you
can find the idea now the idea is rook
to e8 with
check and again there is no move for the
black king only movies Bishop captures
any 8 so we have Bishop captures any 8
and now of course rook to d8 with
checkmate so yeah that definitely a
beautiful game and I do hope it
justifies the title of Britain's Got
Talent as Martin J Gordon shows that he
really was a talented player I did read
somewhere that he gave up on chess and
that he was he was a professor in
Florida so I couldn't really find any
more information on him and if any of
you are able to find a photo of him
please send it to me so I can update my
thumbnail so yeah that's it I would like
to thank Shawn Percel Nikhil Lindh
Jared Lennon jared lee name is actually
this is your second time contributing to
my channel so as I am I do appreciate
the donation but even more I appreciate
that you still enjoy my content after
after a whole month and they'll
Radcliffe so thank you all thank you all
for contributions I really appreciate it
and yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and do
send me that photo if you're able to
find it
thank you